- [Chris] Alright, I
got anyone's attention.
Hello everyone.
Welcome to our session,
our Code Talk on agent code generation
for industrial analytics
and predictive maintenance.
So, I don't know if you've
attended our workshop,
we actually had one as well.
Sea of hands if anyone attended
a workshop we did as well,
as well as our fan club.
It's good. (laughing)
So it's actually a little
continuation from that.
So just special for you.
You'll get to see what we do here.
Alright, so my name, I'm Chris
Azer, I'm a principal gen AI
labs solutions architect.
So I'm part of a team where
I'm a tech lead helping
to drive industry applications
with generative AI
and just showing how we
can improve, you know,
operations and other types of use cases.
And so I've been with AWS eight years
and doing industrial
automation for 20 years.
So happy to share this progress
and where we're at today, right,
where this next form of transformation
and manufacturing really can accelerate
and create agility in being able
to drive operational improvements.
And so I'm joined with Raju.
- [Raju] Yeah, thanks Chris. Hi everyone.
I'm Raju Gottumukkala and I'm
an IoT specialist solutions architect,
and my focus has been really
working with industrial
and manufacturing organizations
in terms of, you know,
helping out throughout
their digital transformation
journeys, right,
starting from how do you unleash
data from machines using,
you know, hundreds of
industrial protocols all the way
to building intelligent models,
you know, that can respond
when there are issues with those machines.
Yeah, over to you Chris.
- [Chris] Alright, so for
our agenda, we're gonna kind
of just talk about some common
challenges in this space by,
if you're from the industrial world,
you may be familiar with those already.
We'll then jump into our AWS stack
and just show you what we're
gonna use today, right,
which AI services, which
IoT services will be used.
And then gonna go through
a couple of tutorial,
you know, coding sessions.
Again, this will be code
that you'll have access to
at the end.
So there'll be a QR
code, you can get access
to our code on GitHub.
So the first one will be around, you know,
looking at anomalies and creating
a repair plan around this.
And then we'll look at it
kind of going deeper, right,
and using advanced analytics
that can actually look at maybe
excessive anomaly detections
you do have, and really trying
to look at a bigger picture
through analytics of
what could be an issue
or relation between maybe
multiple parameters.
All right, so some
common challenges, right?
You know, when we look
at, on the left here,
IoT and OT, I'm sure
people heard this acronym,
we're trying to merge these
two different worlds together,
operational technology and information,
and they just, they operate different.
They have different processes
and different software
and different environments.
So there's a lot of challenges
in this space, whether it's,
you know, lack of response times,
slow digital transformations
because it takes
a certain skill set to implement some
of these latest transformations,
like technology,
whether it's IoT or you
know, AI or digital twins.
There's also this data
analysis gap, a skills gap
that would exist for being able
to create these predictive models.
And with generative AI today.
we've really gotten that ability
to give that to the power
of many people, right?
Being able to do this
kind of complex analysis
on time series data and
really try to find anomalies
or patterns that may exist.
So that kind of skills
gap doesn't exist in both
of these orgs, you know,
readily available, right?
So this gonna lead to costly
downtimes, just accepting
that there's a downtime that
happens with this just machine
or this vendor's machine,
and I'll have to do scheduled
maintenance more often.
There's also a manufacturing skills gap.
There's an aging workforce,
you know, there's people
that are just not there 30 years anymore
and that kind of loyalty, right?
They're leaving with that knowledge.
So how do you enable that
new workforce to be able
to make quicker decisions
and really minimize that response time,
the meantime to respond to a failure?
Other common technical challenges.
Service complexity.
I'm not saying our services are complex,
but just in general
there's a lot of services
that may exist, a lot of
different technologies
and being able to optimize
the use of those services
in a way that would be able
to solve that problem quickly.
So being able to have that learning curve
to understand the services
that I need to use,
the SDKs I need to use
can really slow down
that advancement and agility.
- [Raju] Yeah, so we talked
about the challenges.
Let me start with one of
the common challenges I see
with my customers, right,
is when you're in a manufacturing
facility, you got to deal
with different systems,
different control systems,
OT systems, IT from
different vendors, right?
So the data is siloed in most cases.
So the real challenge is
how do you unleash data
from heterogeneous systems
and then how do you create those contexts
so you can then build
analytics on top of it?
And then you need a reliable
data foundation layer
before you can actually go ahead
and create agentic AI workflows.
So before we talk AI, let's
talk the data foundation
that you need to build the AI layer.
So when I talk about data
foundation layer you need a way
to collect data from machines,
be it, you know, Modbus,
OPCUA, MQTT, or any other
industrial protocol.
You need to collect the
data, model the data,
model the machine, store
the data securely depending
on your price latency trade-off, right,
for your use case.
It could be a real time
operations dashboard
type of use case,
or it could be some post factor analysis
that you do every quarter.
And then once you store the data securely,
then you need a way to egress the data
from that foundation layer, right,
to run your analytics.
Now this is where AWS IoT
SiteWise comes into play.
It's really a purpose built
industrial data service
for industrial and
manufacturing use cases.
Essentially it helps you with
the end-to-end value chain
for industrial data,
starting from collecting
data from machines at age
to buffering data at age
to intelligently publishing
to cloud cost efficiently,
and then storing data in the cloud
and then making it available
for the AI layer, right?
So one unified platform
that gives you access
to all the telemetry and
the knowledge base data.
So we'll use this SiteWise
in our tutorials today
and then show how you can
build that foundation layer
before we build AI agents.
So with that, let's talk
about AI, what we got to offer
and on top of this data foundation layer.
Over to you, Chris.
- [Chris] Yeah.
So before we get into that,
any questions you may have,
this is open.
Open questions.
- [Raju] Yeah, these interactive,
so you can ask questions,
not like workshop.
Any questions on-
- [Chris] Okay, there you go. Yep.
- [Attendee] So I would say probably one
of the biggest things
that I noticed with inside
the IoT space is like kafka
is like nonexistent from
like a transport protocol.
Is that like inside the stack
or do you guys see that like more
and more than Kafka is like
taking over the OTT space
or that transport protocol as-
- [Chris] Do you see that,
you're saying that you're seeing
that more than, use of Kafka more than-
- [Attendee] Well, I'm
actually seeing like less-
- [Chris] Less of it uses.
- [Attendee] It's like not dipping
into the IoT space as much.
- [Chris] Okay.
Yeah, no-
- [Attendee] Do you
see it differently like
with your guys' lens in the industry?
- [Chris] That's a good question.
- [Raju] Yeah. So depends
on the machine, right?
So, and also the throughput.
So MQTT is a good fit, you
know, when you're dealing
with resource constrained devices
that transmit messages frequently,
but not too big in terms
of the message files,
that's a classic scenario
for entity-based messages.
- [Attendee] Mine would be
like post device (indistinct).
- [Raju] So yeah, that's a good question
because in fact we are
working on a few enhancements,
it's still under design.
But the idea here is SiteWise
has all the contextualization
done in it right.
Now you need a way
to extract the data.
Today we provide different ways
to do it using HDK, MCP,
but then one common ask
is, can we extract data
in a data stream format, right, to Kafka?
So today you could do
it through a middleware,
through IoT core.
SiteWise can emit mqtt
messages to IoT core,
and IoT core has a rules
engine that can route messages
to 20 other services, including Kafka.
So you can do it today,
but we are working on some
enhancements to make SiteWise
to Kafka data egress much more efficient.
But there is a way today for
sure that's available for-
- [Attendee] You don't see as
many people doing it, I guess.
- [Raju] No, we do see customers,
you know, asking for it.
We build, we work
backwards from the customer
because we had customers asking for it,
you know, we are building
some more enhancements.
So the quick answer is, yeah,
it's a very common
pattern we see nowadays.
How do I extract data, the contextual data
to your streaming layer
and we are providing
some more tools for you to do that.
- [Chris] Good question.
Any other questions?
We'll ask you again later.
So, okay, so jumping into the AI stack,
you know, this is probably
out of date just after,
you know, yesterday, right?
But we we're just constantly
developing the stack
and the way you look at it,
it starts from the bottom
where we have our infrastructure, right?
So we talk about AI compute,
whether that's, you know,
silicone, like AWS Trainium and
other types of (indistinct),
and other types of GPUs.
We have Amazon SageMaker
for that fine tuning
and that, you know, data
scientist layer, right,
in terms of that kind of
work you would be doing.
We're not gonna be
focusing on that, right?
We're actually in the middle layer, right,
and in the top layer.
So in the middle is
where you actually build
and use services,
configure and use services,
that runs on top of this infrastructure.
So you're not necessarily
saying, I'm gonna use
that chip set, I'm going to,
I want to use this chip set.
We actually abstract that for you
and you just use the service or software.
So there's Amazon Bedrock, which is a,
essentially this platform
that handles many different
capabilities starting
with your choice of
models you want to access.
And in this case we're
gonna use Claude Sonnet 4.
That's one of the LLMS you
can access through Bedrock.
There's other capabilities like guardrails
and you know, other things you
can do, which we won't use.
We're gonna use the knowledge base
to actually access vendor manuals
and specifications that would
be used by the agents later.
And then there's AgentCore, right?
That's where you have a variety
of models you can choose
to pick and choose to use.
You can decide to use Runtime
and run your agents there.
You can use a gateway to access tools.
So there's a variety of
just different modules.
And so what we're gonna do is
actually have a Strands agent
on the top, top right.
That's a open source framework
we have to build agentic applications,
and we're gonna be able to
use memory from AgentCore
so we can contain that
memory in a conversation
that someone like a process engineer
may need to have access to.
On the top, we're gonna
have an application layer
using Kiro.
Anyone, you have heard of Kiro,
I'm sure about this point, right?
This is our a developer
environment we have
and now recently announced
an autonomous agent
that can run off the IDE in the cloud.
And so we're gonna see that
combination of services used.
Ultimately we're gonna help you walk
through building this application
and then executing some of the code and,
and walking through the
code that we would use
to perform these different tutorials.
Alright, so we'll start the
first one. Okay, over to you.
We have to switch over.
- [Raju] Yeah.
Any questions before we
move on to a live tutorial?
And how many of you use
Strands SDK today in your day
to day or weekly or monthly?
Anyone, Strands? Anyone new to Strands or?
- [Chris] Or some use building agents.
Agents? No?
- [Raju] So not many.
- [Chris] Yeah, she's like maybe. Yeah.
- [Raju] Just wanna make
sure so we know, you know,
how much time we wanna spend on Strands
because yeah, this session
is not about Strands,
but more on, you know, how you use Strands
and AgentCore for a
specific domain use case.
So yeah, I'll try to cover
some basics when I do that.
Okay, so in the first
tutorial, so we'll split,
we have two tutorials total,
so probably we'll spend like
20 minutes on each tutorial.
And yeah, if you have any
questions, please do ask.
So in the first tutorial,
so we'll show you
how you can create a workflow,
agentic workflow that
it's made up of three agents
and each with a specialty,
we'll go into the details,
but then the workflow, the goal here is
to create an autonomous
maintenance response
or a repair plan when
there is an issue going on
with the machine, right?
So the prerequisite for
this tutorial, again,
it's all in the GitHub repo,
we'll share that in a moment,
is to have the environment ready, right?
So environment, when I say is SiteWise
with your assets onboarded to SiteWise,
data stored in SiteWise,
and to those new to SiteWise,
we came up with a new
anomaly detection module
of SiteWise natively.
So you can enable anomaly
detection on a machine
without ML expertise.
So we do use that as an
input for this workflow.
So the prerequisite is to
prepare your SiteWise environment
with all your data and
anomaly detection enabled
at least for one asset.
So you have the anomaly result coming out
of that asset, right, the anomaly score,
or some model explainability, right?
So that's the starting point.
Now when you have an anomaly, so we show
how you can create a
workflow that gets triggered
and then that workflow can
then automatically create
a repair plan, right?
So your operations team can
then take the repair plan
and then go ahead with
corrective actions, right?
And we show how you can do
that in a agentic fashion
using three agents, we use Strands SDK
to build these agents.
And then when Chris talks
about the second tutorial,
we'll talk about AgentCore, right?
So let me put down the architecture
for the first tutorial.
So you see pretty
straightforward on the left
we have SiteWise age
collecting data from machines.
So in this example we
use e-bike assembly line
as the sample scenario
and we collect data from
welding station, welding robots
and so on, the conveyor belts.
And then we use one specific
asset, welding robot,
to walk through the workflow, right?
And then on the right,
on the cloud side, you are SiteWise Cloud,
that's where the data is
modeled, sets are modeled
and data is stored securely.
And then we show the agent
workflow that's on the right
that has a number of data sources,
one SiteWise obviously.
And then there is Bedrock Knowledge Base.
So this is where we store all the manuals
for that equipment.
This could be equipment manuals,
standard operating procedures and so on.
And these are all connected
through MCP to the agent, right?
And when the workflow is triggered, again,
it's not one agent we, yeah,
here it looks like, you know,
we are showing it as one agent,
but it's actually three agents
working in a workflow manner.
And then one, the workflow
generates a repair plan
when it's triggered, right?
So the output is we
generate an HTML report,
we will store it in S3, we
will give you a pre-signed URL
so you can access the report, right?
In real world scenario,
this could be etiquette in,
you know, that gets created in, you know,
SAP PM or IBM Maximo.
But here we are just creating the report
and then putting it in S3.
Yeah, that's a high level architecture
for the first tutorial.
Any questions before we move on?
- [Chris] Yeah.
- [Attendee] What's the
trigger point from the sitewise
in the middle to the
predictive (indistinct)?
You guys have an algorithm
that's actually running this,
I actually wanna go to that
or are you sending everything-
- [Raju] So the trigger is an anomaly
being detected in SiteWise.
So that's the trigger.
So now you could define the threshold.
We use 0.5 say threshold
for anomaly scores.
So it's zero to one.
Again, you can adjust
depending on the criticality
of your mission, but 0.5 is the default.
So when we say there is an anomaly,
that's when the workflow
gets automatically triggered.
Now we use IoT core behind the scenes
for event driven workflows from SiteWise.
So today that's the recommended approach.
So when there is an active
anomaly in SiteWise,
SiteWise sends the MQTT
message to IoT Xore
on an event. driven basis,
and then IoT Core will trigger
the the agent workflow.
Yeah, that's the flow.
But for this tutorial, yeah,
we'll manually trigger the workflow,
but that's how you do it in production.
Can you repeat your question?
- [Chris] Your EC2?
- [Attendee] The data simulator?
- [Raju] Yes.
So in this case, we are simulating data
for that welding robot.
So in fact we have a physical
demo that we showcase,
even Venetian, you know,
there is a UVAC demo
that you'll see.
So what we did is we took
the data from a physical demo
and then we are replaying
the data using EC2, right?
Yeah.
But right now we, the
data for SiteWise coming
through EC2, not through SiteWise Edge,
but I still have SiteWise Edge there
because that's the recommended approach.
That's more cost efficient way
of, you know, ingesting data
through the cloud because it batches data
for you automatically.
Yeah.
Yep, please.
- [Attendee] Can I rip out SiteWise
and put something else there
but still use everything else?
- [Raju] Yeah. Yes.
- [Chris] Yeah.
- [Attendee] Is that just a MQTT topic
going in to actually communicate or-
- [Chris] Depends on the
triggering mechanism you would do
in your pipeline to drive an agent action.
- [Raju] Yeah, it could
be a Lambda, you know,
triggering as well.
Yeah, you don't need SiteWise.
We are just showing SiteWise as an example
for the industrial data foundation layer,
but it can be something else as well.
Yeah.
- [Chris] All right, great.
- [Raju] Okay.
- [Chris] Just gonna switch over to demo.
- [Raju] Yeah.
- [Chris] Alright.
- [Raju] Is it agreeable?
Should I zoom in a little bit?
Okay, so the repo that
we're gonna share with you,
so here is a repo on GitHub.
Sample agentic code generation
for industrial analytics.
So what you'll see here, we are just going
through this repo today and
we did all the prerequisites
to save, you know, time for you.
We have a QR code, you know,
we'll share that with you.
We do have that-
- [Chris] Yep. (indistinct)
- [Raju] Yeah, so what you see here
is essentially two Jupyter Notebooks.
So under predictive maintenance,
yeah, this is the first one.
- [Chris] The second
one, oh, the first one.
- [Raju] Yeah, first one.
So you'll see some prerequisites,
so this installs the knowledge base,
uploads the knowledge base documents.
Again, one more thing
to note is this report
is fully self-sufficient.
So you don't need to know SiteWise,
you don't need to know Bedrock.
We prepare the whole environment for you.
We can start with a blank
account, AWS account,
and then use this report.
We do everything for
you from data simulation
to preparing knowledge
base end to end, right?
It's self-sufficient.
So I did the prerequisite
already, so I'll not do it,
but I can just show you.
It's just preparing the
knowledge base using Python SDK.
And in the second example,
so this is the tutorial
for the repair plan
creation using Strands.
So these updated architecture,
but it's pretty much similar
to what we've saw seen earlier.
You can see three agents
working in a workflow pattern.
So, and then we'll go
through, I'll explain some
of the highlights from this notebook.
You can try it later in
your own account as well.
And then on the second tutorial, yeah,
we got a separate notebook.
This is for advanced analytics.
So Chris will talk about this use case.
Yeah, so that's the
repository to begin with.
So I did a clone of this
locally and then I'm using Kiro.
ID.
So I cloned this repo and
then I'm gonna start with,
so I have a virtual Python environment,
so I install all the packages.
Let me show you some dependencies here.
So because we are gonna use Strands SDK,
and Strands tools, so we
have those installed already
and then we use YAML for
some configuration, boto3,
to make certain calls to air services.
So it's all installed.
And now let me actually go
through the tutorial.
So the whole narrative, so
whatever is the use case
that we talked about around E-bikes,
so it's all baked into the
notebook, the whole scenario.
I will skip it for now.
Okay, so I will install
the requirements efficacy
all pre-installed.
So we'll import some modules.
So to those new to Strands,
so it's pretty important
to look into these
three import statements.
So first we are importing
the agent, right?
So this is used to invoke
the agent once we configure
the agent with prompt, system
prompt and foundation model.
And then tool, this is to
create a custom tool, right,
for your agent.
So this can extend the agent capabilities
beyond normal summarization, right?
We use tool here to create the HTML
or to save the HTML document
locally to the file system.
And then we use MCP client.
So we, we have three MCP servers we
are using in this tutorial.
So we got MCP client to
talk to those servers,
and then we use Bedrock
model, Anthropic model to tie
to the Strands agent.
- [Chris] Are people familiar
with agents and tools
and those terminologies?
Like is that something anyone
needs more information on?
- [Raju] You wanna do?
- [Chris] Yeah.
So if you look at agents,
it's gonna think of it
as gonna be like a persona, right.
We're gonna, it's gonna
be our maintenance person,
it could be an operational person, right?
And we're giving that agent
or person tools to do their job, right?
And those tools could be access
to data, access to an API.
And so when we say MCP,
and when we say tool, that's
really the same thing.
And then to confuse you a little bit more,
an agent is also a tool.
So an agent can have a set of tools
and a tool can be an agent
or it could be an MCP tool,
which is access to like APIs.
Now an agent is configured
within instruction.
That's what's different between tools
and agents is you define it in instruction
and the tools it has.
And you'll see that here as
we configure these agents.
- [Raju] Okay?
So we've imported the modules,
so we have some configuration, so we need
to pick the bucket where we
will write the HTML report
and then we configuring AWS
credentials using a profile.
So I'm pointing to a specific AWS account
where I'm gonna create that report into.
And then, so Chris was
mentioning the profile
for each agent, right?
So this is how you define
the characteristics
of the behavior of the agent.
So we create those prompts
in a markdown files,
we call it SOPs, so these are
system prompts essentially.
So you can find them for each agent.
So there is a separate markdown
that explains the behavior
for that, or the profile for that agent.
So for example, for ops data collector,
so this is the agent that
collects data from SiteWise,
so you can see the definition
for that agent, including,
you know, what it should
do, a quick overview
of what it does and what's
expected in terms of the sequence
that the agent should follow
broadly and some constraints.
So it's not completely understood.
So you'll find the SOPs for each agent.
So we are loading those system prompts,
so when we create agent,
we'll tie this prompt
which is in the markdown
file, to the agent.
And then we are loading them.
So I will just run it to load the SOPs.
So the next step is now we'll connect
to the MCP servers, right?
Now let's take SiteWise as an example.
You can talk to SiteWise, you know,
in a traditional way
using SDKs that we offer.
But then now you can use
SiteWise MCP server that we offer
and then plug your agent
so the agent can pick the
right tool that's available
to talk to SiteWise, both for reading
and writing operations, right?
- [Chris] And this tool,
there's a QR code at the end
for this MCP tool.
- [Raju] Yeah, these tools are
publicly available on GitHub,
we have a bunch of MCP servers,
there's some specific tools service.
There are also some
that are quite generic.
Let's say, AWS API MCP
server that can talk
to almost any service.
So we also use that here.
So now we'll create MCP clients to talk to
because MCP's client,
server-based architecture.
So we create MCP client
to talk to those servers.
And here these are the three servers
we are gonna use, right?
SiteWise MCP server to collect
telemetry data for a period
of time and anomaly status
because that's all in living
in SiteWise.
And then another MCP server to talk
to Bedrock knowledge base.
So this is where we retrieve
the knowledge base details
around that equipment from the
equipment manuals and SOPs.
And finally, the API MCP server.
This is a generic MCP server.
We use it to create a file in S3, right?
So I'm not using a S3 MCP server,
but rather a common API MCP.
And then now we are gonna
create some helper functions
to create these MCP clients.
And when you create a client,
you can filter the tools
that you want to make it
available for the application.
So for example, let's say
in SiteWise you get about 50
or so tools part of the MCP server, right?
But you don't need all the tools
for all your agents, right?
If your agent is supposed
to just collect data,
live data or historical data,
you know, from an equipment,
you just need to use like maybe a fraction
of those tools, right?
So it saves you in terms
of the response times
execution time as well.
So we are filtering some tools
from SiteWise in this case.
So I'll show that in a moment.
But then here, this helper function,
all it does is it creates
a MCP client for you
based on the tool filters
and the command that you provide,
I mean, which is the
identifier for the MCP.
So I'll run this, okay, so the
helper function is created.
And then I have one more to
initialize the MCP clients.
So this is where I plug in the environment
and then you can see I have
three clients that I'm creating.
So client number one is for SiteWise,
and here is the identifier
for the SiteWise MCP server.
And then I'm using specific
tools, not every tool,
I just need five tools to
retrieve data from SiteWise.
Similarly, I got two more clients.
So Bedrock knowledge base client.
So here is the identifier
for Bedrock MCP server,
and third is for the AWS API MCP.
So this is the common MCP
server that I mentioned earlier.
So three MCP clients, right,
and then we are just
returning those clients.
So I'll exit here.
So it's done.
So finally, so, so far we
have created helper functions.
Now we'll actually execute,
initialize those three MCP clients
and we get back those three clients.
Yeah, it just takes a minute or so.
- [Chris] So any questions
on this configuration
you're seeing or something
you might wanna apply
to yourself?
- [Attendee] So just to
make sure I understand,
the SiteWise client (indistinct).
- [Chris] On this machine, you mean like,
or what does a client connection occur?
- [Attendee] Theoretically?
- [Chris] Yeah, so wherever
the agent is running,
which could be AgentCore's
runtime as an example,
it would be the client and you would have
to give it this authentication.
But the tool is brought down
to that agent that's running.
- [Raju] Okay.
So yeah, we are done.
We have the clients created
and connected to the servers,
and you can see for each client
the number of tools available.
And with that, let's move on
to creating the agents, right?
So we have the foundation
ready with the NCP.
Now, when you create agents,
you can also define your custom tools.
So, so far we haven't created
any custom tool, right?
We are just using what's
available outta the box from AWS
part of the MCP servers.
So for us, in this case, just to show you
how you can extend the capability
of existing MCP servers
for your agent, here
we are creating a tool
to store the HTML report that
we generate locally, right,
and then that report gets copied to S3.
So this tool, all it does
is it takes HTML as input
and then stores locally.
Now to do that, to store a file locally,
either you can use like a
file server MCP, you know,
that has access to your file system
or you can do something like this, right?
Create a tool that does
a very specific task.
So here we are creating a custom tool,
and the way to do it in Strands
is using the tool decorator.
All it is is a Python function.
You add a tool decorator
and becomes a tool that's available
for your agent, right?
So here, this is a tool to save HTML file.
You can see the definition of it.
All it does it's is it basically saves
the content to a file.
So nothing special here.
So I will create that tool definition.
Yep.
So now we are done with the tools, right?
We have all the tools, some
through MCP, some custom.
The next step is really
creating those agents, right?
So here we'll create some helper functions
again to create the agent.
So first we'll initiate the boto3 session.
So here I'm pointing to
a specific AWS account
using profiles.
And then I'm also picking
the Bedrock model,
the foundation model that
I'm going to use, right?
So for this tutorial, I'm
using Claude Sonnet 4.
So you can change under the model ID.
So these a common model I'm
using for all three agents.
- [Chris] And so with
Strands, you don't have
to use Bedrock, you can
actually use other types
of LLMs in your choice.
So that's an option.
- [Raju] Yeah, it's not tied to Bedrock.
And then it helps you
initialize those agents
as you can see here.
And while creating agents,
there are three things you need
to note, right?
So one is a system prompt,
essentially the profile
definition for that agent,
which we created in a
separate markdown file.
So agent one is ops data
collector, which is responsible
for collecting all the data from SiteWise.
And we have system prompt.
We are now attaching the
tools that are available
and the Bedrock model, right,
the common model that we defined earlier.
So that's the agent one.
Agent two is your knowledge retriever.
So the job here is to retrieve
knowledge related to that machine,
here it's a welding robot,
from the knowledge base, right?
So here we have a separate system prompt
so I can show you how it looks like.
So the definition here, it
says, is for a given asset,
the SOP retrieves relevant
information from Bedrock.
Pretty simple.
You can again fine tune this.
And then we have separate tools, right,
from the MCP, Bedrock tools,
and then we are using
the same Bedrock model
and finally a report generator, right?
So the job here is to summarize
and then create an HTML report
and then to copy that report to S3
and then to give you a pre-signed URL,
which is a temporary URL that's
valid for one hour, right?
Again, in real world,
this could be integration
with your ticketing or asset
management system, right?
So that's pretty much it.
So I will create the helper function
and finally I'll initialize the agents.
So now, so far we've created MCP clients,
we created a custom tool,
and then we've created
three agents, right?
It's creating, the agents
part is still going on,
it should take a minute and
we are almost there, right?
The final step is then
to execute the workflow.
So two agents we created already.
- [Chris] Any questions
while that's executing?
Okay.
- [Raju] Okay.
So yeah, we are done with the,
with creating the agents.
So finally, now, yeah, we need
to execute the agent, right?
So there are some, like when
you deal with multi-agent,
because here we are not just
talking about one agent,
there are three agents,
there are different ways
to design patterns for
multi-agent architecture, right?
And it's well documented in
Strands SDK documentation.
Some common patterns are listed down here.
The swarm, graph and workflow, right?
It really depends on how the,
it really depends on
the order of execution
that's best suited for
your use case, right?
If your use case demands
a sequential execution
of agent one, two, three,
which is probably the best fit
for our tutorial, right,
then you can take a workflow approach.
There is also graph approach
using a DAG, you know,
you can execute your agents
in a DAG, following a DAG.
Topology, or you can have
autonomous coordination
between your agents, right?
You don't define the order,
you leave it to your agents
to decide the handover process, right?
Can be agent one to two, back to one,
to three to two, right?
It depends on the question.
So again, it depends
on really the use case.
You can pick, you know,
one of those patterns.
So here we are using workflow pattern
because all we need is a report
following a sequential flow.
So here is a helper function
to create or to trigger that workflow.
We have all the three agents
and then you can see the
handover process, right?
Because it's a workflow,
we are defining the order.
So step one, we are calling the agent ops
data collector agent with the query,
process anomaly for asset name.
So the prompt here is to process anomaly
for a single asset, right,
which is a welding robot in this example.
And that goes to the agent one.
So agent one will come back
with all the data from SiteWise
for that specific asset, right?
And then it will then hand it over
to the knowledge retrieval, the agent two,
right, in the prompt for this agent two.
Along with the asset details,
we are also providing the
raw information gathered
by the agent one, right?
So that's step two.
And then now you have also,
in addition to sensor data,
the knowledge information as well.
Now we are feeding all
that to step three, right?
And then the prompt here is
to generate a pre-signed URL
for the analysis and then to
store the HTML report locally
and then to copy it to S3.
And then we have some parameters to point
to the right location in S3.
And that's pretty much it, right?
So this is essentially the workflow.
In Strands, there are new
tools that will help you
to manage workflow.
You don't need to manually
define a workflow.
There are better ways to do it,
but right now there's one way to do it.
So now I'll trigger this workflow,
and now you can see the whole interaction
between the agent and
the MCP server, right?
You can see the tools
that the agent is calling
to get the relevant information
depending on the prompt.
So the first step is to figure out,
to identify the asset, right?
So we are asking the agent
to process anomaly for a welding robot.
So it has to figure out
where that asset is SiteWise.
So the first step is it'll
really find the asset ID
for that welding robot and it does it
by calling list asset models,
list assets describe asset,
and then it found the
asset, sorry, the asset ID,
and then using the asset
id, it's making a batch call
because in the system prompt,
we were explicitly asking the agent
to use batch calls wherever possible.
So it is using batch
get asset property value
to get the sensor data from the machine.
- [Chris] So that's really cool.
The agent's able
to look at the tools
and know that the order of
which it should call, which API
to ultimately get to
that ID, right, which is-
- [Raju] Yeah.
And then now you can see
the flow from agent two.
So agent one flow is done,
got back all the central data.
So agent two is now retrieving
the data from the knowledge
base as you can see.
So it's doing a list knowledge base,
it's picking up the right
knowledge base to query.
And then...
Yeah, you can actually see the response
from the knowledge base too.
Yeah, it shows you a
high temperature warning
around 80 degrees for join zero
and some recommended actions
including the error codes.
So these error code is coming
from a knowledge base document, right,
stored in S3 through
Bedrock knowledge base.
And then some recommendations,
you know, like looking
for obstructions and so on.
And then it also did some
analysis around the joint velocity
to give you more insights,
some risk assessment.
Some contact details as
well from the OEM, again,
which is part of the knowledge base.
And then it's generating the report
and then it's saving locally.
Let me show you how it looks like on S3.
Oh, it's gone.
Just gimme one second. I will take a...
Yeah, I'll show you a sample
report while it's running.
Yeah, so this is one I ran
like one hour ago or, yeah.
So what you see here is a report
for that anomaly workflow, right?
It gives you the life
status of the machine,
the results from the knowledge base.
So like I said, the issue is caused due
to high temperature and
high velocity at that join.
So it gives you the error code
map from the knowledge base,
some root cause analysis
from the knowledge base,
action plan.
Again, this can be formatted, right?
You can fine tune the system prompt
to format the report, that's possible.
So yeah, see the maintenance
schedule, some warnings,
contact details and so on.
So yeah, that's pretty much it.
I wanted to show in
this tutorial, you know,
like how you can start
all the way from no agent
to prototyping a multi-agent
workflow to help you,
you know, troubleshoot
issues with your machines.
Now this is pretty much
for prototyping, right?
So when you're trying to move these agents
to production environment,
so that is where
you would probably look into
something like AgentCore,
and where you make your MCP servers
and tools more discoverable
using AgentCore.
Right now we are doing
all locally using Strands.
Really great for like
prototyping in this case.
So now I'll hand it over to Chris.
So before I do that, let me
give you a quick context, right?
So in this tutorial we did a,
we processed one anomaly,
right, in a operational context,
in a live operational context.
But then when you see
anomalies occurring regularly,
frequently for a type of
mission from a vendor,
for example, for a period
of time, you may want
to dig deep into, you
know, what's going on,
what are those common patterns, right?
So that's where advanced
analytics comes into play, right?
So this is where someone
from the operations team
or a data scientist would
actually go into and see,
look into, you know, different equipment
under the same equipment class,
same equipment class for
example, to see, you know,
what's causing those
frequently occurring anomalies.
So Chris will show you
a different workflow
that will help you do
exploratory analytics, right,
on again, the same,
it could be same machine
class like welding robots
to look at a historical data set, right?
Let's say last two years or
last two months or six months.
And to give you some common
patterns that you can use
and prevent anomalies
from happening, right?
But this workflow we saw is,
let's say you have an active anomaly,
how do you respond, right?
That's what we are
showing in this tutorial.
But in the next tutorial we'll show more
on historical data analysis, right?
That's where advanced
analytics comes into play.
- [Chris] Okay.
- [Raju] Any questions before
we hand it over to Chris?
- [Chris] Great.
Alright thanks. (indistinct)
Yeah, so we're gonna, like you said,
go some advanced analytics
and so we'll just kind
of paint the picture.
There's this trying to address
the manufacturing skills gap, right?
So the challenges that we have
a need to access, you know,
data insights and really do this quickly
without having to rely
on external IT teams
and data scientists to really
analyze the big picture
of why I have maybe an excessive
anomalies being detected.
So think of Sarah,
she's a process engineer
and she sees that motor 01
is sounding off again, right?
One of my joints is
triggering again, an issue.
So with this we want to show how we
can use Bedrock AgentCore
and first party tools
that it has, tools that
we build and maintain,
to actually execute and
generate code on the fly.
So you ask it to do some
analysis, it will start
to pull NumPy and SkyPy and
all these other libraries
used for data analytics
and really start to take that data
and bring it through a whole, you know,
even creating machine learning,
linear regression models.
It's really pretty fascinating.
You'll see what it does.
So it looks up, you can
look up equipment specs,
you can look up other information you need
in this process of analysis,
and this all happens in the sandbox
within that AgentCore environment.
And so that's what code
interpreter does here, right?
It lets you execute and
generate code securely.
And you can do this on
large scale of data, right?
We're thinking like could be gigabytes
of data you might have
that you want to take
through this analytical process.
And it makes it easy to use.
It can execute code in JavaScript
and TypeScript, Python and
other types of languages.
All right?
So that's what we we're gonna see,
process engineer, we'll talk to the agent,
it will then pull access
from code interpreters
and other data points to run that code
and then store it in memory.
So with AgentCore memory, we're able
to actually store this
conversations and these results
and then Sarah can come back
and say, Hey, you know, I have
a follow up question, right?
And essentially with memory
module for AgentCores,
you can create short-term
memories and long-term memories.
So imagine like you have this
lot, a lot of conversations
that occur over a period of time.
You might be able to create
this semantic relationship
between things and it
can recall that memory
for you when you talk to it.
Alright, let me go back
to, switch to demo.
Yeah.
Okay. So we'll go to advanced analytics.
I'll close out some things.
Okay, so here's initial start here.
We'll actually go ahead
and install the libraries
like we need like before,
so we won't have to go into that detail.
We will actually create
this code interpreter module
and substantiate that,
and it's based on regions.
So we support a couple of regions,
I can't remember all of them,
but we're gonna use US East
One, which is Virginia.
And this is part of
the AgentCore libraries
that we're using.
So if you look above, there's
actually this AgentCore
Python library that we'll use
for accessing code interpreter.
All right, let's go ahead
and load the equipment data
that we have from the anomaly
test that we did, right?
We're seeing now we're
generating excessive amount
of anomalies and we need
to really do some deep analysis into that.
- [Attendee] How many rows
are in that data frame right there?
- [Chris] How many rows ended up-
- [Raju] Thousand
- [Chris] Thousand?
- [Raju] We want it to be
done quickly, so it's pretty-
(group laughing)
- [Chris] It executes and
then we'll wait for 20,
30 minutes.
- [Raju] Yeah, it's just one month
of data sampled every minute.
- [Chris] Yeah, so you see several joints,
temperature, velocity, and
various types of joints
that exist in that robotic arm.
So we're trying to get through that.
Alright, that's done right?
Okay, we need tools, right?
Helper functions, this is
like you saw, we won't go
into that detail again,
but this is something that,
you know, Raju mentioned, right,
you need some helper
functions to open files
and also prepare for
the sandbox environment.
So we're taking some of that data
and putting into a CSV into that sandbox
and then more helper tools, right,
to be able to call that tool.
So these are not that
important, but writing
and listing the files
you have in the sandbox.
So we're gonna create that as well.
Now here's a great part,
right? The fun part.
You're creating that
agent's persona, right?
So you're telling them you
are an industrial IoT data
analyst assistant, right?
And so you're specialized really
in detecting this equipment
health and monitoring.
And it gives you all
these principles you have
and the tools you might want to access.
So you need to execute
Python and CD output.
So we'll go ahead and
create that system prompt,
which we'll use coming up soon.
Now we want to create our tools.
So I'm gonna go ahead and create
a tool for code interpreter
that Strands will use.
I'll create one for the
equipment knowledge.
So we'll create that as well.
And then we need to enable memory.
So in this example you'll see it,
it's actually you don't want
to use this code in production,
but it's, it's looking
for the existing memory
and it's like wiping it out, right?
So you can start fresh.
So you don't wanna be wiping
your memory every time
this thing runs, but it just
kind of gives you an example
of how you can set up your
memory and create hooks.
So with AgentCore you can create this hook
where every time there's a
response, the hook triggers
and it takes their memory and stores it.
So that's what we're doing in this code.
And so if we go down to
the bottom, you'll see
that it's found that
existing memory, right?
Oh, it's active, I'm
cleaning up your old events,
deleted 18, memory is now
ready for fresh analysis.
So just be aware of that, right,
when you're looking at this code.
Now with Strands and agents,
you need to now configure that to be aware
of the memory module.
You need to be aware of the tools it has.
And so that's what we're
actually configuring here
is configuring the model
to use the memory hooks
that we're gonna have
for the memory module.
And then this line of code,
we want agent with memory.
So we create that agent,
we (indistinct) the model,
the tools that will
have that system prompt,
the hooks that will then
trigger the memory module
to be used.
Any questions on that line?
That's an important line, right?
'cause you're actually like
really setting up the
agent's capabilities.
Okay?
Now one more helper function for displays.
We'll go ahead and run our first analysis
and that's probably the time we'll have.
There is actually more
follow-up questions we can do
to really test the memory.
But we're gonna actually run this example
where the welding robot has
several anomalies lately
and we want to understand,
you know, what kind
of overall analysis you can
perform on that data file.
So let's go ahead and run this
and I'll minimize this code.
So look what it did, right?
Code, generated code,
import pandas, import NumPy,
import matplot, right?
It's actually like a data
scientist creating the code
that it will use to do this analysis.
It starts creating its own plots, right?
So I'm gonna create this
cullable so you can see.
This takes about a
minute and a half, right?
So as you see it create, you
know, the different graphs
for anomalies, different
bound, lower and upper bounds.
These are things I don't
know myself, right?
I'm not a data analyst,
but really gives you the
power of oh no, what happened?
Okay.
- [Raju] I think it's a throttling issue.
- [Chris] Might be.
- [Raju] Yeah, we are
limited to how many calls
we can make to Bedrock
model during this week.
- [Chris] Yep.
- [Raju] Yeah, it could
hit again. Yeah, hit again.
- [Chris] Yeah, we'll
give it a second chance.
Yeah, this is a lot of
usage on Claude for sure,
but it gives you idea, you'll be able
to execute this hopefully as well.
If this fails again, hopefully it doesn't,
but you'll be able to
execute this on your own
and see the results.
Yeah. Okay.
Alright.
Well what would you
see is essentially just
as a result, it would have the,
it would actually show the correlations
between these different anomalies
and different sensor issues
and be able to tell you that, oh, okay,
this is what's something
you need to perform
a repair plan on or perform
more scheduled maintenance against.
And so there's different
types of advice I would give
that's really helps you
create that direction on
how you can optimize your equipment.
Maybe there is specific specifications
or settings that you need to
adjust to the machine specs.
So it's really cool, it
gives you a whole report.
I wish I could show you that end here.
- [Raju] Yeah, you
wanna try one more time?
- [Chris] Sorry, one more
time. I have a video.
It failed back too.
- [Raju] Yeah, let's pull
out the video and see
if it works this time.
- [Attendee] It's like
the meme where it's like,
sorry boss, props down,
but I ran out (indistinct).
- [Chris] Yeah, I know, right?
Yeah, no, it's like Claude gets
hit a lot during re:Invent.
So it's all these workshops and-
- [Raju] Yeah, but you can
already see the analysis, right,
in the print statements, right?
So it says there's no strong
correlation between sensors,
so it's trying to print into a report.
Where it's failing is
generating that report,
but the analysis, it's already being done.
You can see the distribution
of simultaneous analysis.
You can see that it's
finding the common patterns,
the baseline behavior for certain sensors.
And also the data quality.
It also checks that missing data,
gives you a data quality report,
which could be causing
maybe false positives
as anomalies in SiteWise.
Yeah, that's another
insight you could get out
of this advanced analytics report.
- [Chris] We get lucky.
Third time's a charm?
Any questions while this loads?
We got three minutes left.
So that's is your chance,
- [Raju] You wanna show the console maybe
in the meanwhile, the console.
- [Chris] Oh yeah.
- [Attendee] What does
production look like?
Like at scale.
- [Chris] For this type of solution?
Like a, and you're providing it
for the analysis point of view.
Let's just advanced analysis. Yeah.
So you're giving that access to-
(attendee speaking faintly off mic)
50,000 devices, I mean
whether you're perform it
across all those, right?
There's you trying to
look at it holistically as
an issue that might be occurring
across many devices and sensors.
- [Attendee] It's more
like this right here,
like how does this scale out?
Even (indistinct) manufacturing plant,
you have 500 to a thousand devices
inside of single manufacturing plant.
So like from a production perspective,
are you heavily reliant on site SiteWise
to be able to actually go
and pinpoint what gets sent
into here and so forth?
- Yeah. It leaves that up to human decide
some of those things, right?
Likeas opposed to like
giving it all the data points
and saying make sense of this, right,
if there's a particular operation
or process area that you're looking at
and you're trying to
address potential issues,
then you might be able
to narrow your scope.
- Yeah. But from a data
management spec, yeah,
SiteWise is fully managed,
it's highly scalable.
So we have customers using
SiteWise for thousands of assets.
They onboard those assets
and then SiteWise can scale
in even in terms of anomaly,
you know, giving out you
those anomalies, detecting
and triggering event based
workflows that's highly scalable
through SiteWise because
it's fully managed for you.
- So it actually ran for time.
- Yeah.
- So we see critical issues found right?
Joint zero, urgent attention required.
We see 27 extreme temperature
anomalies reading up
to 87 degrees Celsius.
And so it shows this
like correlation between
joint temperature and velocity anomalies
and really starts to break
down these issues, right?
It also looks at what are
normal operating ranges.
(attendee speaking faintly off mic)
There is some specs that
it pulled from the machine
to know these are my operating ranges.
It looks at the data points
correlates that together,
creates all that code
to perform that analysis
and create those plots
like you saw in the code.
- I mean the more context
the better, right?
So in this case it's just the sensor data
and the knowledge based documentation.
But you can bring in
more MCP servers to talk
to more systems.
You get a better analysis.
- We also said like we
intentionally made some data missing
and it detected that too saying, Hey,
I see data quality issues, you know, 67%
of this missing across joints.
And so that's, I saw
your hand up there. Yeah.
What's your question?
(attendee speaking faintly off mic)
By updating your index.
and update your embeddings
and do you want the rest,
the manual stove bit, that joint
temperature range is a typo
(attendee speaking faintly off mic)
or something you wanna hold on the update
If you identified the chunk
where that's embed, we extract
that from, but I can get,
I, that's a good question.
I need to follow up and we do
after and see how we can do that.
But yeah, it gives you a full
report of what you need to do
and maintenance recommendations.
- You can further enhance
it to show like plots.
So we're not showing plots here.
You can do pay wise plots,
correlation analysis,
and we can do a scatter plots
and all that part of the workflow.
We are not displaying,
we are actually doing
it, but not displaying.
- Great.
- Yeah. Oh, we are time.
- Yeah. Oh, we are at time.
- Any questions on what you've seen?
(overlapping chatter)
and you can try it in your own account.
And the second is the list of MCP servers.
I think we are pointing to SiteWise MCP,
but in the same GitHub
repo you'll see all the CPS
that we provide to talk to
a number of AWS services.
And third is some examples
to get started with AgentCore
to really scale your agents
to production. Right?
- Yep.
- So
- Awesome.
Well thank you. Thanks
for joining our session.
- Thank you. Thank you all
for spending time with us.
Thank you.